montando a caballo así es como llegan a
honduras miles de nicaragüenses con la
esperanza de recibir la vacuna contra el
kobe 19 la búsqueda la hacen en dos
pasos fronterizos aduaneros empujados
por la carencia de suministros en su
país de origen empezaron el anterior
jueves por invitación del presidente
hondureño
la solidaridad y hermandad de los
hondureños traspasa las fronteras
habilitamos punto de vacunación en
frontera con nicaragua para aplicarte
250 500 dosis al día contra el cob y 19
a nuestros hermanos nicaragüenses
inoculan a las personas mayores de 12
años con modernas y a las embarazadas
con fai ser obviamente estamos muy
agradecidos porque este gobierno se ha
preocupado más por nosotros que nuestro
propio gobierno y han sido muy amables
en tenernos paciencia porque somos un
exceso de persona increíble ya estamos
aquí todos días tenemos de estar aquí
por una vacuna imagínense lo que tenemos
que pasar nosotros los nicaragüenses por
la irresponsabilidad del gobierno de
nicaragua la vicepresidenta de nicaragua
rosario murillo aseguró que el estado
nicaragüense ya vacuno al 53 punto 87
por ciento de su población sin
especificar si lo han hecho con el
esquema completo sin embargo la
organización our world in data refuta al
gobierno asegurando que nicaragua ha
inoculado apenas al 5% y que usaron
además de los fármacos permitidos
vacunas que carecen de la aprobación de
la o ms como las cubanas abdalá y
soberana 2 debido al difícil acceso a la
vacunación en el país centroamericano
también españa noruega panamá y la india
han donado dosis para los nicaragüenses